the ones who run into steakhouses
playing sounds of cows being slaughtered
they're the ones that Munch avocados and
almonds invariably yeah and by the way
and they are dining upon the
reproductive organs of plants that's
kind of weird and I imagine if if a
plant-based alien visited Earth they
would freak out when they saw
vegetarians yeah because the vegetarians
would be eating them right and and
vegetarians Target
um not only the reproductive organs the
nuts the berries the flowers but they
also Target the infant versions of it
baby lettuce baby carrots baby this
would terrify a plant-based alien so
that's just a cosmic perspective on that
no no you've given me you have given me
a whole new line of attack the the
flower babies I love it this is
fantastic